you i i found this out i did not know
this but you literally helped rebuild la
in the 70s as a construction worker and
i didn't know that
well i mean the the thing was that uh
even though i was a bodybuilding
champion
and i won mr universe five times in mr
olympia
and mr world and all those competitions
uh i still didn't make any money from
bodybuilding
it was totally uh on an amateur level in
those days you know the football players
were getting all the money
and basketball players and baseball
players golfers
but not bodybuilders so we had to kind
of create slowly an industry so
franco made by training partner who came
from italy
uh and i we started a construction
company because he was actually a
bricklayer
and so we put an ad in the early times
that said you know
european bricklayers and masonry experts
uh
you know available for rebuilding your
fireplaces or whatever your patios or
whatever
and then a week after we put the ad in
the early times
uh there was an earthquake
and a huge massive earthquake i think it
was a 6.9 or seven earthquake
and it wiped out a lot of the gymnasts
and a lot of the patios and
instructors in houses and all this so
frank and i were so busy we had to hire
like a bunch of bodybuilders
and other people to help us with the
construction work so we did a lot of
work and made some really great extra
money
oh my god that's so the timing of that
oh my god you put your ad out and then
everyone's place gets destroyed so you
have work that's amazing that's
amazing timing
you